bienvenue à vous sur france 5 arte vous
nous rejoignez les 19 heures à paris à
la une de l'actualité la france a une
nouvelle première ministre et isabelle
borne c'est le premier acte de politique
intérieure du deuxième mandat des
modèles macron vous l'avez vu elle a
salué jean castex on va assister en
direct ensemble à cette passation de
pouvoir entre jean castex donc il a
remis sa démission à emmanuel macron et
elisabeth bornes qui était ministre du
travail et qui devient donc la première
femme enfin en tout cas ça fait 30 ans
qu'une femme n'avait pas été nommé à ce
poste est bien devient la première
ministre française elisabeth bornes on
va en parler avec mes invités on va
suivre en direct cette passation de
pouvoir j'ai plaisir d'avoir à mes côtés
déjà à dominique de montvalon bonsoir
éditorialiste politique bienvenue à vous
roselyne febvre est toujours avec nous
chef du service politique de france 24
françois durpaire va nous rejoindre un
historien spécialiste des états unis qui
connaît aussi très bien la politique
française et roland cayrol politologue
directeur du ctal le centre d'étude et
d'analysé conseil en stratégie image et
communication qui va également nous
rejoindre on peut dire tout de même
dominique de montvalon que cette
nomination d'une femme c'est vraiment ça
sera un marquant un marqueur de ce
nouveau mandat de d'emmanuel maquereau
en tout cas ce sont un événement il y
eut et u2 ya maintenant de plus de 30
ans la nomination d'edith cresson snap a
d'ailleurs été encore pas s'appesantir
là dessus une réussite complète dans un
climat un peu machiste et puis la
commune aussi quelques erreurs
j'étais jeune journaliste à l'époque été
témoin mais restons en restant à la
situation d'aujourd'hui c'est
intéressant ce qui va se passer là c'est
très intéressant un nouveau premier
ministre dans une situation sociale et
politique difficile c'est de toute façon
un événement est une femme
au fond on attendait depuis quelques
jours mais que ya six mois qu'on me
aurait imaginé que ça puisse être
elizabeth bande très peu à mon avis
c'est intéressant l'intéressant de rosen
vous allez réagir on va voir d'abord
tout de suite à matignon notre envoyé
spécial florent rdo florent rebond soir
vous êtes sur place on a tant fait on
est en pleine passation de pouvoir on
peut le dire
ça y est en tout cas il avait devant
nous est arrivé dans sa nouvelle maison
ici à matignon elle est passée à trois
mètres d'eau dans la voiture qui
l'accompagné avec jean castex le visage
fermé c'est ce qu'on a pu voir
d'elisabeth bornes il doit évidemment
prendre conscience de la lourde tâche
qui elle va l'occuper pendant ces
prochaines années ou en tout cas ces
prochains mois on verra bien sûr le
résultat des législatives les 12 et 19
juin en tout cas les événements de ça y
est arrivés ici avec jean castex elle a
pu sortir de cette voiture elle est
actuellement en train de s'entretenir
avec l'ancien premier ministre a donc
donné sa démission emmanuel macron aux
alentours de 16 heures à l'elysée les
deux hommes qui sont entretenus un peu
moins d'une heure voilà l'entretien
entre elizabeth bornes et son
prédécesseur désormais jean castex
devrait durer une petite demi-heure le
programme a pris un peu de retard
puisque nous annoncer son arrivée ici à
18h30 il est déjà 19 heures donc on
devrait avoir la passation de pouvoirs
aux alentours probablement deux à 19h30
et jean castex qui va bien sûr mettre au
courant de tous les dossiers importants
elisabeth bornes elisabeth band qui a
déjà été briefé d'une quelques sortes
par emmanuel macron dans son bureau
c'était tout à l'heure après l'entretien
qu'il a eu avec jean castex plus de 150
invités sont ici présents dans la cour
de matignon ceux bien sûr qui ont
travaillé avec jean castex et qui sont
venus lui rendre un dernier hommage on
attend donc la sortie de l'ancien et de
la nouvelle première ministre dans une
demi heure environ pour leurs premiers
mots bien sûr florent et quelle est
l'ambiance sur place on voit qui est du
monde tout de même
oui je vous le disais environ 150 à 200
invités un ca à vue d'oeil ou comme je
vous le disais ce sont principalement
des des personnels de matignon ambiance
feutrée il ya eu quelques
applaudissements au moment de l'arrivée
la voiture lorsque jean castex et
elisabeth bande sont sortis de leur
véhicule quelques applaudissements
feutrée et puis on a accompagné jean
castex et les avait deux bornes à
l'intérieur la garde républicaine et
bien sûr la le décorum est bien sûr
toujours aussi impressionnant pour cette
passation de pouvoir s'est donc à un
moment historique on peut le dire un pur
pour la france 31 ans après la
nomination est d'edith cresson est
l'unique première ministre de la france
je j'écoutais votre invité qui disait
qu'à six mois bien personne n'aurait
sûrement parier pour les abonnements de
c'est vrai et il faut aussi rappeler
cette cote de popularité 19% seulement
ans mais voilà il y avait des bandes qui
est un un profil qui ne devrait pas
faire de l'ombre à emmanuel macron qui a
donc choisi une femme pour être à
matignon ces prochains mois tout du
moins florent vous restez avec nous a
menacés en direct de matignon puisque on
va suivre ensemble cette passation de
pouvoir marc joie sur ce plateau roland
cayrol bonsoir politologue directeur du
cdn centre d'études et d'analysés
conseil en stratégie en face de vous
françois durpaire bonsoir françois
historien spécialiste des états unis
mais très intéressé par la politique
française rôle puis rosinter est
toujours avec nous roland cayrol joué y
ait un petit peu opiné du bonnet la
relance qu'il parlait lorsqu'il disait
justement une femme une femme ça sera
sacré marqueur tout de même pour ce
deuxième comme première décision du
deuxième mandat d' emmanuel macron ça
fait quand même moment confié à temps
wima faire c'est d'être le cas c'était
pas le cas mais ça fait trois semaines
qu'on nous dit ça sans doute une fable
et c'est très important que ce soit une
femme lui dit c'est très agréable
c'est très important alors pour du coin
31 ans voilà et en plus sans être
méchant avec personne la première avait
pas laissé un souvenir toujours éclatant
et d'y créer sans cesse qu'elle disait
dominique de montvalon voilà dac d'eau
qui est quand même une espaces de
l'image à remonter pour les valeurs
politiques
françaises commencent bien parce que si
on estime qu'il faut qu'une femme
remonte et oui il peut être la
compétence ou le niveau alors peut-être
faut leur faire confiance souvent parce
que si on a une tous les 31 ans est vrai
que ça va être compliqué peut-être cela
dit ça a été très compliqué d'ailleurs
elle a été une des premières à réagir
les dites cresson avec son franc parler
qui faisait pas plaisir il ya 31 ans et
qui fait toujours peut-être pas plaisir
aujourd'hui elle a dit que notre pays
est un prêt arriérés et donc il est bon
que ça change et d'ailleurs c'est assez
paradoxal parce qu'elle est 10 parce que
10 c'est important que ce soit une femme
mais en même temps a dit faudrait pas
que ça soit commenté le fait qu'on en
parle on se demande déjà les commandes
déjà et il faudrait pas que ça soit
commenter parce que ça devrait être
complètement banalisé après tout deux
grandes démocraties occidentales
autour de chez nous de chez nous la
france ont eu des femmes chefs de
gouvernement dans des régimes
parlementaires thatcher gala merkel l
amérique est assez importante mais
d'autres très grosse démocratie sont pas
en reste du côté arrêt de la france je
rappelle que les états unis certains
disent la première démocratie du monde
n'ont jamais eu de président de femmes
moyenne vice
première fois roselyne on en parle
forcément oui mais je trouve ça je
trouve ça pathétique en fait aujourd'hui
de se dire que un c'est un moment
historique et que deux une femme à
matignon whaou quand on consomme qu'on
s'en étonne en vérité ça me choque un
peu parce que comme si voilà
une femme était une sorte de choses qui
devraient faire ses preuves alors que
l'on disait dans les démocraties qui
nous entoure que ce soit en europe du
nord ou même un peu plus loin en
nouvelle-zélande ce sont des femmes et
personne ne se pose la question de
savoir si voilà c'est une femme un
martien de droite de gauche de fabre peu
importe vous voyez ce que je veux dire
c'est que voilà c'est la compétence on
peut pas à la fois dire on veut une
égalité femmes hommes et ne pas faire de
différence et s'extasier un jour qu'une
qu'une femme soit premier ministre d'un
pays comme le nôtre d'un tout petit mon
nom sur une tout à fait mais c'est le
communiqué de la présidence de la
république qui nous oblige à quand même
commandé ce fait mais bien suisse qui
lie à écriture inclusive elle est nommée
première ministre il ya 31 ans elle
était premier ministre et son effet
nommé au poste de premier ministre là on
a un changement même dans l'écriture
dans notre dans notre manière de
concevoir le heureusement que ça a
changé depuis heureusement 2000 on
parlait d'une période très particulière
que c'était intéressant de l'observer
que vouliez vous dire
je ne sais pas qui vous faites allusion
mais vous avez sûrement déjà en tête ont
ceux qui s'extasient devant la
nomination d'une femme productif non
j'entends bien dans les jeux on n'est
pas dans un dialogue non mais c'est le
salaire on va des jeux lire il se trouve
je suis en face ce pourrait ne pas être
le cas totalement en phase avec roland
cayrol que le passage de décret sont à
matignon n'a pas été globalement
favorable aux téléspectateurs c'était
moins d'un an
ça a beaucoup surpris quand françois
mitterrand l'a nommé là et sanaa ça n'a
pas été une réussite c'est un c'est un
monde machiste en france la politique on
revient de très loin
que n'aurait-on pas dit si nous n'avions
parole si nous n'avions pas relevé et
puis on va passer à autre chose là on va
parler de la personnalité d'elisabeth
baume par exemple et de la majorité
qu'elle aura auquel n'aura pas elle
fonctionne en harpe a relevé qu'
effectivement c'était quand même un
événement est une femme edith cresson
parce qu'elle
est un événement mais bon alors cette
femme c'est dommage c'est que voilà on
en fait un fait totalement inédit pour
la troisième occasion
roland cayrol alors une femme il avait
deux bornes évidemment elle a travaillé
à la réforme de la sncf lé
polytechnicienne elle a été directrice
de la ratp d'eiffage ministre des
transports et donc 5 ans ministre des
manuels macron d'abord à l'environnement
puis sociale donc en fait on disait sur
ce plateau quelques auch tout les cas
c'est un peu ça isabelle borne est ce
qu'elle va être capable de dialoguer
avec les syndicats il ya du pain sur la
planche au point de vue social
économique elle koch effectivement ces
cases là je crois qu'elle koch toutes
les cases en tout cas qui compte ce qui
intéressait le président de la
république
on l'a dit c'est une femme elle est
polytechnicienne vous l'avez rappelé et
son ingénieur c'est une femme de
dossiers d'arrangement institutionnels
c'est une vraie culture d'ingénieurs
qu'elle représente ce qui est assez rare
dans la classe politique française on a
plutôt des juristes ou des énarques lé
polytechnicienne elle a travaillé sur
des dossiers extrêmement technique les
transports d'abord l'écologie ensuite et
finalement le social et chaque fois elle
a bossé c'est d'abord une bosseuse
et identifiés comme tels et puis elle
s'est causé avec les syndicats elle aime
ça elle l'a fait dans l'entreprise
qu'elle avait dirigé un moment la ratp
elle l'a fait quand elle a été ministre
du travail et elle connaît le langage
syndical elle connaît la culture des
organisations syndicales s island
évidemment elle va en avoir terriblement
besoin en même temps on dit qu'elle est
dans la gauche gouvernementale parce que
l'été dans ce petit groupe territoire et
progrès qui est en effet de centre
gauche mais il faut bien voir quelle va
être extrêmement mal reçue par la gauche
ça commence le soir d'ailleurs avec
mélenchon qui parle de saccage social
les mêmes mots que marine le pen les
mêmes eaux que marine le pen et qu'est
ce que je veux dire c'est que
ça n'est pas parce qu'elle a fait de
l'écologie au ministère et parce qu'elle
vient de plus centre gauche du
gouvernement que ça va apaiser les
choses sur le flanc gauche
d'ici les législatives
car justement voir parler on va d'abord
retrouver à florent rodo encore une
nouvelle fois à matignon on attend cette
passation de pouvoir entre jean castex
elisabeth bornes d'un instant à l'autre
flanc
absolument c'est toujours la grande
attente ici dans la cour de matignon où
environ 150 à 200 invités ont été
conviés des membres du cabinet de
l'ancien premier ministre désormais jean
castex qui s'entretient en ce moment
même dans son bureau avec elisabeth
bornes du rock est situé bien sûr
derrière nous les deux enfin jean castex
et isabelle demande qui vont tout à
l'heure sortir pour la passation de
pouvoir officielle bien sûr ce moment
très important de la vie démocratique
française pour un petit discours bien
sûr ou et j'avais devant devrait
remercier jean castex pour son action
ces deux dernières années un an et dix
mois marqués bien sûr par le sceau de la
pandémie de qu'ovide 19 des crises
sociales évidemment forte les abbés
demande vous l'avez dit elle aura du
pain sur la planche notamment mettre en
oeuvre la transition écologique ce
virage à gauche qu'un blanc chez
emmanuel macron entre le premier et le
second tour de la présidentielle cette
retraite à 65 ans bien sûr qui fait
grincer des dents à gauche elizabeth
banks est une femme d'expérience haute
fonctionnaire elle a fait l'école
polytechnique ont ancienne directrice de
cabinet de ségolène royal et vous l'avez
dit trois fois ministres avant de
devenir la première ministre et ministre
des transports ministre de la transition
écologique et solidaire avant d'être
ministre du travail ces deux dernières
années et c'est sa capacité à dialoguer
avec les syndicats qui est bien qui fait
qu'elle tenait la corde depuis plusieurs
jours c'est donc la fin du secret de
polichinelle elisabeth bande et bien à
matignon pour les prochains mois tout du
moins on vous restez avec nous au
françois durpaire peut être rebondir sur
ce cas on dire roland cayrol sur ce
thème en cette gauche qui dit déjà que
elle et elle va être ça met le saccage
social avec elisabeth bornes elle-même
venant de la gauche du centre gauche
législatives bien sûr qui arrive mais
c'est ce que vous venez un instant déjà
un de souligner c'est qu'on a les mêmes
mots sur twitter pour marine le pen qui
je griller la politesse là on sent qu'il
ya quelque chose qui joua à
mélenchon qui lui fut en quelque chose
de plus classique mais exactement les
mêmes mots c'est à dire saccage social
dont l' attaque non elle n'est pas de
gauche est intéressant d'ailleurs marine
le pen aille vraiment dans cette
direction aussi ça c'est la première
vous dites coché toutes les cases c'est
une expression qui paraît à d'autres qui
est pas une expression journaliste et
que c'est des macros lien qui utilise
beaucoup cette expression non et on les
répète alors vous dire qu on les répète
mec alors j'ai dit que si la dame
exactement de cette expression mais pour
le coup et koch toutes les cases sauf
une elle n'est pas élue locale et ça
pour le coup quand il on se dit bah il
faut qu'elles viennent de la gauche il
faut que ce soit une femme il faut
quelle est l'expérience il faut que l'on
garde quand même un petit peu la
nouveauté mais là bon c'est pas quand
même on y reviendra un petit peu
d'écologie vie publique vie privée mais
élu local ça en a pas on ne pouvait pas
non plus
celle qui coché le plus de matches de
castres c'est justement dans ce contexte
d'élections législatives qui arrive dans
quelques semaines elle va représenter
tout de même la majorité il va falloir
qu'elle se bat elle s'est représentée
dans dans le calvados me semble-t-il
donc ça ça va être sa première mission
oui déjà de conduire la liste et puis la
deuxième mission c'est de gagner et
ensuite
eh bien ça va de tenir la majorité en
espérant pour eux qu'il y en ait une
voilà et
voilà les après il y aura tout de suite
après sept projets de lois pouvoir
d'achat très important c'est pour ça qu
emmanuel mac on voulait se profile aussi
sociale à la fois techno à la fois
compétente bosseuse comme le disait
roland qui aime qui aiment femme de
dossiers en quelque sorte et voilà de
faire passer les lois
pouvoir d'achat spa pas difficile
puisque je pense pas que l'opposition se
refuse de voter une loi pour le pouvoir
d'achat sans fin ou alors on allait plus
loin voilà alors fatalement ils voudront
voilà ils voudront toujours plus etc et
puis après le dur du dur ça va être si
il y à cette réforme des retraites qui
va être quand même quand même le gros
sujet dont on parle depuis cinq ans
puisque emmanuel macron on n'a pas pu le
faire empêché par le par l'épidémie
voilà et là c'est peut-être la personne
idoine pour effectivement discuté avec
les partenaires sociaux
des gens qui emmanuel macron avait un
peu traités au début de son quinquennat
par dessus la jambe en expliquant que
c'était des ralentisseurs et qu'on avait
plus besoin de vieux ustensiles en
quelque sorte et au fur et à mesure et
l'aap compris appris que bien ne pouvait
pas s'en passer dominique de montvalon
justement sur cette représentativité de
la majorité dans ces législatives ça va
être une vraie bataille pour elle parce
que comme le disait françois durpaire
les pas élu local donc ça pour le coup
ça va tendre se demander si il faut
évidemment qu'elles gagnent parce que
comme dit rosine si elle perd est ce que
ça veut dire d'ailleurs que ce sera la
fin l'histoire sera terminé a peut être
pas d'emblée à peine vient-elle d'être
nommé déjà d'envisager son échelle mais
la bataille pour les essais timides mais
j'entends dire j'entends bien écoutez je
me souviens de ce que de ce fait pas
dire la vox populi la voix la voix
général dans les médias lorsque le son
prédécesseur avait été nommé ou est-ce
que macron est allé pêcher ce premier
ministre quelles compétences pourrait-il
à vous ce qu'on a dit sur elle
de faire le comme s'ils voudraient qu'il
ya un malentendu là j'étais en train de
faire le commentaire de ce qui se passe
à france 24 je parle en général oui je
vous dis ce que j'ai entendu tout à
l'heure enfin bref c'est pas non mais
là les
alizés qu'est ce que vous avez entendu
jeudi qu' à l'époque ah non mais moi je
dis ça ces jeux débutée il ya longtemps
j'ai il y avait un scepticisme narquois
qui entourait la nomination et je suis
modéré dans l'expression qui entourait
la nomination de yoff peut-être en
partie
je le partage est la nomination de le
prédécesseur de des abeilles bornes et
aux gens qu'ils l'aient oui jean castex
et aujourd'hui on le voit avec tout
compte fait une densité et il va laisser
un souvenir kiné qui n'est pas médiocre
alors laissons la vivre ils sont là
vivre
qu'elle ne va pas elle ne va pas l être
le chef
politique de ces élections elle n'est
pas là pour ça elle est là pour être la
première analyse de macron celui qui est
le chef de la majorité politique
jusqu'aux législatives c'est de macron
c'est lui qui est de gagner les
législatives et il le sait parfaitement
parce que je veux bien quelques auch pas
la case de du local mais elle cause
surtout pas la carte la case du charisme
politique c'est une personne extrêmement
sérieuse extrêmement compétentes qui a
beaucoup de qualités elle est pas une
chef politique c'est pas elle qui va
allait galvaniser les foules et qui va
porter les candidats dans des meetings
effréné non c'est le boulot de macron il
va probablement gagner ses élections
puisque tous les sondages le montrent
qu'il n'y a pas de raison que cette fois
ci se trompe il va gagner les élections
elle sera à ce moment là la chaire
politique de la majorité parlementaire
mais nous ne demandons pas d'affronter
les élections à mon avis elle aurait
même intérêt à cesser d'être candidate
dans le calvados pour faire son boulot à
l'hôtel matinée en vain
j'ai très intéressé de voir quelle est
la composition du gouvernement qu'elle
va diriger quand on va le reconnaître
c'est ça va nous donner des indications
intéressantes
c'est à dire par davos qui est
intéressant c'est qu'effectivement il
n'est pas question qu'il soit qu'apporte
qu'est ce que la leader de cette
campagne mais en revanche c'était
intéressant dans la nomination de ne pas
prendre quelqu'un qui allait gêner cette
campagne est là pour le coup et elle est
quelqu'un qui fait consensus le richard
ferrand n'est pas contre françois
bayroux à partir du moment où c'est pas
lui il n'y a pas de souci pour que ce
soit elle christophe 4 sagna et c'est en
fait c'est quelqu'un qui est apprécié et
donc là il n'y a pas de raisons
effectivement pourrait premier ministre
2 2 de macron il a promis de passer de
la verticalité à une semi horizontalité
on va voir ce que ça va donner mais en
tout cas il faut pas avoir un charisme
exceptionnel et d'ailleurs jean castex a
gagné sur ce point là on dit souvent
c'est 50% action 50% communication le
premier ministre mais sur le volet
communication technique opérationnel et
fera comme jean castaings qui est cette
expression aussi assez abominable ces
derniers jours de dire il a tellement
été bon jean castex qu'il faudrait un
jean castex en femme bon ils ont trouvé
peut-être le jean castex ensuite
amoureux de l'entente avis non seulement
la dernière formule mais déjà l'été
fillon qu'il faudrait exactement alors
que le péno mais justement est-ce qu'il
n'a pas appris en communication jean
castex roselyne parce qu'au départ c'est
ce que disent et demi mon ballon vous ne
savez pas très bien qui c'était ils l'a
appris oui bah tout le monde je viens
apprend tout le monde apprend tout le
temps
mais
oui mais il a appris sans vraiment faire
de grosses bourdes je trouve le trou qui
s'en est quand même pas mal sorti voilà
c'est c'est le grand commis de l'état
qui n'a pas d'états d'âme qui le fait la
mission qu'on lui a confiée enfin
peut-être qu'il en a mais en tout cas il
l'aimé pas sur la table
on a pu savoir que derrière le rideau et
faisait preuve parfois d'autoritarisme
parce que il faut aussi avoir une poigne
pour bâle et parfois les ministres c'est
aussi la cour d'école il faut il faut
que les choses soient dites qui est pas
de quelques feux ni etc donc voilà ce
qui était votre question des jeunes
justement sur la façon dont il avait
appris à communiquer philippe michon mal
non mais communiqué il avait raconté à
ses voiles a alors appris à communiquer
franchement ça n'a jamais été un grand
tribun
franchement jean castex quand on
l'écoutait on s'endormait qu'au bout
quand même au bout de dix minutes après
ça n'enlève pas son talent sa compétence
et son rapport à ces équipes ou quoi ou
à son travail mais globalement il ne
faisait pas non plus nos gais comme
disait roland il ne galvanise pas les
foules il avait ce côté assez marrant
parce que il était assez naturel donc
comme ce jour où il cherchait ses
lunettes qui était sur son nez donc
voilà donc c'est ça reste un personnage
un peu sympathique
qui faisait plutôt un peu 4e re et 18
ici la mort la province important tout à
fait franche avec des mini montréal en
plus la plupart des leaders politiques
qui sont au premier rang terre paris
précise elle a absolument et ça c'était
une elisabeth bout parce que les
premières critiques ça va pas tarder à
voir maintenant en plus comme il ya des
sites toutes des journaux ou m'attendais
et des sites en ligne on a tout de suite
c'est techno le mot techno il revient
tout le temps donc là on sent poindre et
les quelque chose elle était beau et il
connaît bien ses dossiers connaît-elle
la france alors là pour le coup il ya
quand même une rupture avec jean castex
qui est arrivé en disant toutes les
trois phrases territoire territoire
territoire c'était quand même une
bouffée d'air pur des territoires et de
la province à paris juste vous
interrompre à ce qu'emmanuel mâcon vient
de réagir sur twitter chère isabelle
borne madame la première ministre
écologie santé éducation plein emploi
renaissance démocratique europe et
sécurité ensemble avec le nouveau
gouvernement
nous continuerons d'agir sans relâche
pour les françaises et les français en
quarts voilà revenu maquereau en a
vraiment pour les pour les nouvelles
victoires comme dirait l'eau en avant
pour une nouvelle victoire est ce que
florent rdo est là avec une réaction
peut-être à ce tweet
voyez absolument emmanuel macron qui a
donc eu une journée chargée puisqu'il a
reçu tout à l'heure jean castex et qui a
eu une journée chargée également sur
twitter piste un peu plus tôt il a
remercié jean castex pour son action et
les résultats je cite obtenu ensemble
vous l'avez dit emmanuel macron qui a
publié un nouveau tweet pour donner
finalement la feuille de route à
elisabeth bornes qui lui a donné bien
sûr en tête à tête tout à l'heure vous
l'avez dit écologie santé éducation
plein emploi renaissance démocratique
c'est évidemment le nom du nouveau parti
des manuels mâcon qui remplace en marche
europe et sécurité évidemment emmanuel
macron le le pro europe on attend encore
d'un instant à l'autre la sortie
d'elisabeth bandelettes arrive ici à 19
heures et les 19h23 la passation de
pouvoir pourrait avoir lieu dans cinq à
dix minutes ici cette feuille de route
qui a donné emmanuel macron jean castex
est également en train de lui confiant
en ce moment même les dossiers
prioritaires ce qu'ils ne font qu il
faudra absolument mettre en oeuvre ces
cinq prochaines années le programme
également c'est dans les 24 48 heures la
formation d'un nouveau gouvernement on
nous dit qu'un conseil des ministres
habituellement vous le savez prévu
mercredi pourrait avoir lieu jeudi voire
vendredi on va évidemment suivre ça la
composition du gouvernement qui va bien
sûr nous donner indications sur la
politique qui va être menée lors de ces
cinq prochaines années on attend
évidemment aussi le résultat des
élections législatives les 12 et 19 gens
qui pourraient venir chambouler tout ce
beau programme pour emmanuel macron
bancaire aulas effectivement à feuille
de route des mamelles macron là et elle
est chargée jeudi santé éducation plein
emploi renaissance démocratique europe
et sécurité il ya du boulot et il faut
quand même bien se rendre compte pour
ceux qui nous qui nous regardent qu'eux
alors qu'on vit dans un régime très
présidentiel c'est quand même le
président qui tirent tous les fils de la
politique française ou internationale
vue de la france en même temps le poste
le plus lourd dans la vie quotidienne
c'est celui de premier ministre parce
que tous les fils de l'administration
française ne mène pas à l'elysée mais il
mène à matignon il ya donc tous les
jours une centaine de décisions à
prendre d'arbitrages administratif ça
n'arrête absolument jamais c'est pour ça
qu'on parle de l'enfer de matignon c'est
pas tellement long sphère politique il
faut arbitrer entre les ministres ça
déjà c'est pas toujours facile mais
cette idée qu'on est le chef suprême de
l'administration et que le moindre
problème s'il ya une chicaya quelconque
entre un préfet un maire etc tout
remonte là et ça ne remonte pas
le premier ministre toujours appelé le
président entend lutter là qu'est ce que
je fais mais pour la plupart des décès
jours il est tout seul avec sa décision
il y en a une centaine par jour on
saturday intéressant qu'il parle
d'europe aussi et sécurité emmanuel
macron en nommant justement sa première
minute ça reste fait partie évidemment
ces dossiers importants mais qui ne veut
pas porter seul en tout cas lorsqu'on
voit 7 8 mois c'est pas le mot que je
retiens de ce tweet mais ça chacun prend
son mot je retiens un mot c'est le verbe
nous continuerons alors donc on a fait
une campagne sur le vous rappeler alors
on a dynamité continuité ça c'est
intéressant parce que c'est là pour le
coup c'est nouveau la campagne n'a pas
été faite sur la continuité elle était
faite sur le thème vous si vous m'élisez
vous n'aurez pas le même président et il
y avait une nouvelle méthode il y avait
et c'est tout allait changer
et là on a passé cinq ans à dire et en
même temps alors que ça va être quoi les
cinq prochaines années peut-être 1969
vous rappelez du slogan de georges
pompidou le changement dans la
continuité
ça marche
mais le premier du score premier
changement c'est un merveilleux
merveilleuse sur daugan echard marche
tout le temps d'ailleurs on ne sait pas
qui l'attribué mais vous avez sans doute
raison mais souvent sans fin fond de la
campagne en tout cas il ya un point
important c'est que en disant continuité
il valide aussi
elisabeth bornes parce que elisabeth
bornes elle sort pas de nulle part et il
est à la fois trois fois ministre soit
gouvernement mais elle est aussi la
première premier ministre première mini
ce pardon dit viens de 2,2 d'emmanuel
macron à être issus de son parti
politique qui change de nom d'accord
mais à l'issue de son parti politique
donc c'est compliqué d'en faire
l'incarnation d'une nouvelle méthode et
d'un changement complètement tonitruant
à roselyne mais en même temps il avait
parlé de nouvelles méthodes emmanuel
macron pour ce deuxième mandat me
semble-t-il oui enfin on a eu on a eu
droit quand même pas mal de fois la
nouvelle méthode au cours du quinquennat
on en a eu pas mal donc
il a essuyé pas mal de nouvelles
méthodes donc changement dans la
continuité oui prendre comme on aime
dire ce que j'appelle ma français sera
emmanuel macron après c'est quelqu'un
qui corrige assez vite et qui comprend
très vite ses erreurs et qui s'est très
vite rectifiée maintenant il a eu il a
mis cinq ans pour pour apprendre pour
comprendre les erreurs
aujourd'hui il a compris qu'il n'avait
pas été élu par l'amour des français
mais parce que effectivement il n'y
avait pas non plus grand choix et qu' il
n'avait pas pu aussi nous non plus faire
en 2017 dans lors de son premier mandat
ce qu'ils vous laissent des réformes et
un peu renversé la table de cette de ce
pays un peu trop sclérosé trop belle
trop avec des couches de
l'estrade des strates administratives on
regarde les images d'un rosine parce que
ça se précise on sent que la passation
de pouvoir devrait avoir lieu à la
vraiment c'est imminent c'est maintenant
on les voit jean castex et elisabeth
bornes descendre donc les marches la
passation de pouvoir eh bien on va la
suivre ensemble en direct jean castex
donc tire sa révérence et tu vas passer
donc le flambeau à il avait d'abord la
nouvelle première ministre française
toute nouvelle première ministre
mais s'attend au gouvernement de montmel
montaud
[Applaudissements]
madame
madame la première ministre sheikh
elizabeth
mes chers concitoyens mesdames et
messieurs je suis cher elisabeth
particulièrement heureux de t'accueillir
ici à l'hôtel matignon siège
la chefferie du gouvernement dans un
moment toujours solennel et je tiens à
le dire d'emblée particulièrement
émouvant pour moi
je voudrais d'emblée si tu me le permet
exprimer toute ma gratitude et ma
reconnaissance
après c'est moi qui depuis
juillet 2020 m'ont conduit à la tête du
gouvernement de la république à faire
face avec le peuple français à une série
d'événements tout à fait exceptionnelle
difficile douloureux
et je voudrais d'abord exprimé
évidemment ma reconnaissance au
président de la république de m'avoir
fait l'honneur et donner la possibilité
d'exercer cette
très haute fonction
et j'allais dire tout simplement de
servir mon pays
je voudrais dire aussi au peuple de
france
combien je sais que les mois écoulé
marqué par une crise sanitaire
inédites ont été
difficiles
combien cela engendre et de décès de
souffrance
combien nous avons dû prendre
sous l'autorité du chef de l'état des
mesures difficiles mais je veux ici
saluer
résilience
de nos concitoyens
la solidarité qui sont exprimées au delà
de contestation qui se sont fait jour
mais dans l'ensemble
nous avons ensemble fait face
j'ai essayé
avec le gouvernement avec l'ensemble des
services publics de mener le bateau dans
ces circonstances tout à fait
exceptionnelles avec je le redis un seul
objectif
protéger
apaisé
expliqué
rassembler fédérer
ses remerciements je les dois aussi
évidemment
à l'équipe gouvernementale
dont tu faisais cher elisabeth parti et
au delà de cette équipe
à mon cabinet bien sûr au service
exceptionnel qui tu le verras travail
ici à matignon mais tu les connais déjà
pour l'essentiel et au delà à l'ensemble
des agents et fonctionnaires de l'état
et du service public
pour ceux qui en doutaient
ça n'a jamais été mon cas la france a
montré
qu'elle disposait d'un état et d'agents
du service public formidable bien sûr
bien sûr
comment ne pas évoquer d'abord celles et
ceux qui concourent à notre service
public de santé publics et privés
d'ailleurs qui depuis le premier jour
ont fait face avec un courage et une
abnégation absolument exceptionnel à
toutes les vagues d'à pandémie combien
de fois me suis-je rendus à leurs côtés
dans les services de réanimation
d'urgence dans les hôpitaux dans les
établissements de santé dans les centres
de vaccination je veux leur redire en
votre nom la gratitude infinie de la
nation pour ce qui s'est passé nous
avons mon gouvernement a tenté à la
demande du chef de l'état d'en tirer
déjà ça c'est appeler le ségur toutes
les premières conséquences pour remettre
à niveau ce service public dans la
pandémie a rappelé nous elle fois le
caractère absolument indispensable et je
sais cher elisabeth que tu aura à coeur
de poursuivre cette action ma
reconnaissance s'exprime également aux
membres du parlement et notamment à la
majorité parlementaire qui m'a toujours
été fidèle d'une grande loyauté qui a
pris ses responsabilités
et je crois dans le plus grand respect
et de l'état de droit et des
prérogatives de la représentation
nationale
la crise sanitaire vous le savez n'a pas
été le seul événement auquel nous avons
dû faire face plus près de nous
évidemment
la guerre aux portes de l'europe anne
ukraine qui n'a pas fini de faire peser
toutes ses conséquences y compris ici
dans notre pays et je sais que c'est une
des priorités que tu auras coeur de
traiter
mais
je veux avoir une pensée particulière en
ce moment aussi pour les victimes des
attentats
des attentats terroristes qui ont
meurtri notre pays
alors que je me trouvais ici à l'hôtel
matignon
je pense bien sûr
à samuel pâtit
l'attentât de conflans sainte honorine
mais je pense aussi à stéphanie
m'enfermer
et l'attentât
terrible dans ce commissariat
je pense aussi aux victimes aux trois
victimes à notre dame des anges anniv
je pense aussi à ce policier assassiné
en avignon tout cela marque beaucoup la
nation et renforce notre détermination
et je sais combien tu l'as partage
à lutter sans relâche contre le
séparatisme et le terrorisme
je me suis donné sans retenue à cette
belle et haute fonction en veillant
toujours à ce que je crois
fondamental
à ces valeurs que nos concitoyens
attendent eux par dessus tout au delà
des décisions qu'il nous faut prendre
l'engagement la sincérité
le bon sens et la proximité
la société souffrent certains de nos
concitoyens
rencontrent des difficultés
à le peuple français est un peuple
exigeant tu le sais il ne prend rien
pour argent comptant
il le soupèse tout
mais il sait faire face c'est un grand
peuple un peuple politique
la fonction share elisabeth n'est pas
davantage
exemple d'exposition et de critiques
andy même elle a été créée pour ça
et là ce cher elizabeth je crains qu'une
de ses critiques tu sois épargné celles
relatives à ton accent personne n'est
parfait
n'oublie pas quoi qu'il en soit
que en réalité
il y à ce qu'on entend beaucoup
qui s'expriment fort et oh
et puis il y à ses millions et ses
millions de nos concitoyens
que l'on n'entend jamais ou si peu et
qui sont là qui observe qu'ils agissent
qui mènent leur vie fait comme les
autres deux heures et de malheur il faut
veiller à ne jamais les oublier
il ne s'épanche pas forcément sur les
réseaux sociaux
il n'occupe pas forcément
les chaînes d'information continue mais
ils sont là et ils sont la colonne
vertébrale de la france
cette france qui est confronté tu le
sais à d'immenses défis
la crise sanitaire n'est pas tout à fait
terminée
tant qu'ils annulent crenn et toutes ses
conséquences sont là la question du
pouvoir d'achat sur laquelle je le pense
mon gouvernement a déjà beaucoup agi va
occuper pour renforcer et amplifier et
dispositifs que nous avons pris loin de
toute mesure de démagogie et de facilité
qui aurait pour conséquence que
d'affaiblir durablement notre économie
et d'appauvrir davantage encore à
l'arrivée les plus vulnérables d'entre
nous
j'ai confiance chez elisabeth d'abord
permets moi de te le dire en trois temps
je te connais je te vois agir tu étais
au gouvernement avant que je n'en
devienne le chef mais depuis juillet
2020 j'ai pu je veux le dire à la nation
observé t immenses qualités de droiture
d'intégrité de compétences de
volontarisme
ton aptitude certaine à relever les
grands défis que le président la
république a soumis au peuple français à
l'occasion de l'échéance majeure qu'est
l'élection présidentielle la transition
écologique
l'égalité des territoires
l'aspiration à la justice et à l'égalité
toutes ces valeurs que tu as ancré en
toi même et depuis longtemps surtout
j'ai confiance dans le peuple de france
dans les grands talents que celui ci
recèle pour qu ensemble
de façon solidaire déterminé par notre
travail par nos efforts
partager nous puissions fasse faire face
à ces grands défis
je serai autant que tu le souhaites à
tes côtés ma chère elisabeth
comme je les dis est annoncée je ferai
en ce qui me concerne un pas de côté en
sortant de la vie politique nationale
dans laquelle je ne suis finalement
rentré qu'un peu par effraction en
juillet 2020
je continuerai bien sûr à servir notre
pays il ya tellement de façons de servir
son pays quand on lève en dehors de la
politique
à toi même au gouvernement de la
république et à l'ensemble de nos
concitoyens à notre pays à l'europe
aussi je souhaite de tout coeur
bonne chance
je souhaite le meilleur car je n'en
doute pas nous en sommes capables je
vous remercie
qui
monsieur le premier ministre cheikh jean
merci tout d'abord pour ton engagement
sans faille au service de notre pays au
service des françaises et des français
tout au long de ces derniers mois
merci aussi pour tes mots et puis merci
pour les nombreux combats que nous avons
menés ensemble précisément au service
des français
alors je suis sûr que beaucoup de
françaises et de français ont comme moi
un pincement au coeur au moment où tu
t'apprêtes à quitter ses fonctions
parce que tu as su conquérir le coeur
des français en sillonnant sans relâche
notre pays en allant à leur rencontre
tu le sais je crois que tu as
certainement battu tous les records sur
le nombre de déplacements d'un premier
ministre mais ça nous a permis de
découvrir au delà de thé grande qualité
d'écouté et d'apprécier des qualités
humaines
tout à sincérité et toute ta capacité
je veux dire d'empathie vis-à-vis de nos
concitoyens
alors tu l'as tu l'a rappelé quand tu as
pris ses fonctions il ya bientôt deux
ans
les défi était immense d'abord la crise
sanitaire était toujours là dans notre
pays et on nous annonce et une crise
économique et sociale sans précédent
grâce à ta détermination à ton
engagement je pense qu'aujourd'hui on
peut le dire les résultats sont là nous
avons pu protéger des entreprises le
taux de chômage est au plus bas depuis
15 ans nous avons agi pour le pouvoir
d'achat même si tu l'as dit il nous
faudra continuer à agir tout au long des
prochains mois
moi je voudrais dire à quel point j'ai
apprécié de travailler
à tes côtés pendant ses 22 mois alors
nous avons évidemment des différences
mais je pense que nous avons aussi
beaucoup de choses en commun
d'abord nous partageons la conviction
que les politiques publiques doivent se
bâtir dans le dialogue le dialogue avec
les élus avec les partenaires sociaux
avec les associations avec lesquelles
nous avons travaillé sans relâche tous
ces derniers mois et puis même si nous
venons de familles politiques
différentes
je pense que nous sommes également
attachés à l'intérêt général à la
cohésion de notre pays à l'égalité des
chances et ça j'ai pu le mesurer
notamment dans les projets que nous
avons porté ensemble pour la jeunesse
alors vous pouvez compter sur moi pour
poursuivre dans cette voie face aux
nombreux défis que tu a rappelé qu'ils
sont devant nous je pense notamment à la
situation internationale mais aussi aux
défis climatiques et écologiques sur
lequel il faut agir plus vite et plus
fort et je suis convaincu que nous
pourrons le faire en associant encore
davantage les forces vives de nos
territoires parce que c'est bien au plus
près des français qu'on trouvera les
bonnes réponses et c'est bien tout le
sens aussi de la nouvelle méthode voulue
par le président de la république
alors comme vous l'imaginez je suis
évidemment très ému ce soir et je ne
peux pas m'empêcher d'avoir une pensée
pour la première femme qui a occupé ses
fonctions
edith cresson et peut-être je voudrais
dédier cette nomination à toutes les
petites filles en leur disant aller au
bout de vos rêves et rien ne doit
freiner le combat pour la place des
femmes dans notre société
[Applaudissements]
monsieur le premier ministre cheikh gens
je pense sincèrement que vous êtes une
personne rare parce que vous privilégiez
toujours le collectif et que vous
incarnez ce qu'est un ministre ce qu'est
un premier ministre c'est-à-dire
quelqu'un qui sert son pays donc merci
très sincèrement ibra vous
on croit
voilà vous mettiez dans la passation de
pouvoir entre jean castex le sortant et
elisabeth bornes lentes rentrent donc la
nouvelle première ministre française on
a vu donc jean castex évoqué ajustements
qu'il s'était donnée sans retenue à ce
poste et elisabeth bornes qui a parlé du
pouvoir d'achat de cette nouvelle
méthode du président de la république
d'associer les forces vives des
territoires encore plus et qui dédient
qui dédie sa nomination à toutes les
petites filles at elle dit aller au bout
de vos rêves dominique de montvalon une
réaction je vous la formule a du sens
oui c'est intéressant et c'est du
classique y compris j'avais j'ai un
sentiment les écoutants l'un et l'autre
qu'il a il avait presque oublié en
chemin
les français si je puis dire je suis un
peu rose en disant ça mais et qu'ils se
parlaient eux en disant on a été bon
ensemble on a su trouver les chemins on
vient de deux familles politiques
différentes peut en attendre points
communs bon il ya un moment il faut
revenons sur terre mais voilà c'est un
exercice obligé ça fait partie de du
rituel républicain et je le respecte
toujours on verra ce que ça donne
[Applaudissements]
sur terre oui non c'est vraiment c'est
vraiment un rituel il y a le premier
ministre qui était venu parce qu'il s'en
va et il ya le personnel de matignon qui
est encore plus ému parce que ça a été
le plus grand premier ministre on n'est
jamais rencontré et il doit faire
l'éloge de son successeur de sa success
rice il veut le faire dire au revoir et
son dernier disque voilà ce secteur il
remercie ses collaborateurs et la
première ministre on savait que c'était
pas une oratrice mais on le sait encore
plus je fais confirmé oui c'est ce que
vous retenez de deux sont du nombre
d'entre eux sont grands discours ce sera
celui où les présentera le programme de
son gouvernent lorsque l'assemblée
nouvelle aura été là elle aura un
programme de gouvernement a présenté et
il faudra qu'elle montre un talent
d'organisation d'un discours là
franchement elle s'est contentée
rapidement de céder aux ruptures rituel
de la passation des pouvoirs elle a fait
le boulot mais voilà on n'attendait pas
autre chose enfin à d'horaires de la
cinquième pays qui a eu des passations
difficile et a eu des passations plus
facile aux passations difficile de 1962
on se rappelle michel debré georges
pompidou ce n'était pas cette est pas
terrible du tout c'était même
catastrophique et très proches puis on
en a eu des plus chaleureuses là ça fait
partie peut-être des plus chaleureuses
qu'on est vraiment très haut sans qui
s'apprécient bien qu'ils s'apprécient
vraiment le deux choses importantes
c'est vrai que il l'a dit et connaît
déjà le personnel de matignon et donc
elle a été nommée aussi pour ça parce
qu'elle est directement immédiatement
j'allais dire opérationnel nous parler
vinci nuitées et va s'entendre
extrêmement bien va santander secrétaire
général de l'elysée il le faut avec
alexis colère havas s'entend avec tout
le monde et ça c'est important on ne
savait pas s'il fallait parler du fait
qu'elle était une femme ou pas elle a
tranché en dix ans la part les petites
filles c'est très important et d'anlyses
hommage qu'ils se sont faits l'un à
l'autre c'est important qu'elle ait
rendu hommage au premier ministre des
territoires celui qui a voyagé qui s'est
déplacé qui a sillonné fils âgé
acquérant voir parce que généralement
quand on dit je sais par milla que tu ai
fait ça c'est pour ces pour faire à peu
près la même chose si elle était
complètement fermée à matignon et kaba
pas sur le territoire on dira alors
pourquoi a t'il at elle dit ça
j'essayais d'un mot qu'en fait non
pardon parce qu'il me retirer mon
agrégation d'histoire c'était
effectivement pompidou en 69 le
changement dans la continuité
et c'était pour se distinguer d'alain
power à l'époque du scar n'a fait que
continuer l'héritage de pompidou
roselyne cette passation de pouvoir bon
écoute et quand ça a été très bien
résumé par roland cayrol c'est à dire
que voilà cd autosatisfecit on a été
formidable tu seras formidable nous
serons formidable ils seront formidable
donc voilà je vous récite le le
bescherelle ou deux
blade
adieu jean castex à jean castex avoir
été salut il a aidé dans son discours il
a exprimé plusieurs fois le mot service
public ce qui incarne vraiment l'homme
qu'il est en quelque sorte à dire un
haut commis de l'état un grand commis de
l'état qui a fait sa mission voilà est
qui
qui comme il le dit à mener ces données
sans retenue comme il a dit on va aller
voir florent au dos sur place il s'est
donné sans retenue jean castex à vous
assister à tout cela un florent sur
place est vraiment ce sont vraiment les
adieux de jean castex là qu'on le voit
effectivement on a vu aussi le premier
première prise de parole des diabètes
board jean castex qui va sortir donc de
matignon vous êtes avec nous
florent
ça y est c'est fait jean castex est
sorti de matignon il y à peine cinq
secondes très applaudie vous l'imaginez
bien par tout le personnel ici de de
matignon on a senti l'émotion d'ailleurs
un de jean castex pendant ce discours il
a évidemment remercié le président de la
république pourra lui avoir confié les
rênes du pays pendant un an et dix mois
il a bien sûr rappelé à elisabeth devant
les défis qui l'attendent bien sûr sur
le plan social sur le plan écologique
évidemment il avait deux bandes qui a
été très applaudi pour la première fois
vous avez également relevé cette phrase
tout à l'heure je dis à toutes les
petites filles de ce pays qu'il faut
aller au bout de ses rêves elle a rendu
un hommage appuyé à edith cresson
dernière et surtout seul première
ministre de la france étaient entre 1991
et 1992 exterran de la peine douze mois
et qui s'est mal terminée pour edith
cresson elisabeth bande qui ça y est a
pris ses fonctions officielles
à l'hôtel de matignon elle a désormais
24 48 heures pour présenter évidemment
en concertation avec le président de la
république le prochain gouvernement de
la france emmanuel macron elisabeth
dante qui vont bien sûr avoir des
relations très très proche bien sûr dans
ces prochains jours pour cette formation
du nouveau gouvernement on retiendra
notamment dans la prise de parole de
jean castex ce remerciement à la france
silencieux ces millions de français
qu'il a dit qu'il ne prenne pas la
parole sur les réseaux sociaux qui ne
sont pas là sur les chaînes de
télévision en continu mais il l'a dit à
elisabeth bande c'est la colonne
vertébrale de la france ne jamais elle
est oubliée voilà ce qu'a dit entre
autres jean castex à elisabeth dans la
passation de pouvoir qui s'est déroulée
devant nos yeux et ceux de la garde
républicaine environ 150 à 200 invités
étaient ici présents jean castex qui a
été très applaudi au moment de sa sortie
il est sorti à pied avec sa compagne il
vivait ici un pendant deux ans avec sa
femme et trois de ses quatre filles la
fin de l'expérience matignon entre
enfants aujourd'hui pour jean castet
merci florent on l'a vu à partir dans
cette voiture jean castex et donc la fin
de jean castex et le tout début de ce
premier ministre elisabeth bornes de
cette première ministre un tout dernier
mot peut-être dominique montvalon alors
là tout va s'accélérer parce que là les
prochains jours c'est l'ensemble du
gouvernement qui doit être nommé puis
ensuite un discours de politique
générale effectivement ça va s'accélérer
l'étape qu'on attend tous évidemment
c'est la composition du gouvernement ça
ne donnera d éclairage important sur les
rapports entre les uns et les autres et
la tonalité politique emmanuel macron
véritable chef d'orchestre évidemment
veut donner à ce début de quinquennat
blanquer en ligne
pourrait se dire que ça devrait aller
très vite puisque il a pris son temps
mais ça va quand même duré quelques
jours parce que au dernier moment c'est
toujours très compliqué il ya tellement
d'arbitrage affaires politiques
géographie institutionnelle qu'il ya
toujours des problèmes merci beaucoup
d'avoir été avec nous roland cayrol
merci à vous dominique de montvalon
merci françois durpaire merci roselyne
febvre merci bien sûr à floro d'autres
étaient avec nous en direct de matignon
et merci à vous tous de nous avoir
suivis et vous restez avec nous sur
france 24 est plus d'informations via
sur france 24 va revenir sur cette
nouvelle première ministre il avait deux
bornes en france
[Musique]